hey guys it's des if I don't think here
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of 300 rise of an empire
directed by Noam Murro yeah I need me
here to off so wasn't Zack Snyder even
though everyone thinks it Zack Snyder he
co-wrote it produced it yes what I mean
when you watch it it definitely has the
first 300 ago so overall I enjoyed it I
liked it wasn't as good as the first one
but i thought it was entertaining yes i
actually liked it more than the first
round yeah i was surprised I 300 movie I
always like I never loved it knows movie
i thought was entertaining thought I
probably did a good job I thought this
movie and again not trying to oversell I
guess this isn't like gladiator anything
but I thought it brought a little bit
little more layers to the characters I
like sullivan stapleton I'm big fan of
strike back so I was a big fan of his
portrayal of from the bunch of these
names domestic please things I say his
name I like that he was he wasn't just
yelling all the time like this is sparta
tonight we died and i was like yelling
all the time like i like to yeah I just
thought his performance it was a little
bit more reserved but I did a great job
and I think one thing this movie had
that 300 didn't have was an awesome
villain and Eva greenest it's her move
this is her movies yeah I give this
movie to anybody it's her and she just
owns it she's a yeah she was fan art
museum yeah and I like the background to
her and just her character i did a good
origin story hazaea mm-hmm I am I
complaint is that there wasn't enough
Lena Headey I was kind of hoping more
for her character Queen Gorgo King
Leonidas is widowed would we get a third
one might probably see more yeah we just
cut but I was kind of actually hoping
for her to be a bigger part all right in
order for her and like Eva Green to like
right butt heads even even if not
physically strategically she just right
you know that was my complaint ok I
won't go into I don't want to spoil it I
don't want to people but she's not in it
as often is all right you would think i
was gonna say i think if you haven't
seen the film 300 in a while and i know
i had and i think they did a good job
the kind of throw out the mood they'll
show some old footage of the original
300 and the kind of
we've it should say salt I like 30 some
years old but they keep it though weave
it into the story cuz it's not really a
sequel it's almost a companion piece it
takes place alongside of 300 there's
some parts that had their then after but
it's not really necessarily a true
sequel but it's are those well done I
like the cast like the look again Eva
Green just owns it she was the standout
role and again Stapleton did a good job
as the leading male of this one a little
different then draw but not take away
from Gerard Butler but just a much
different performance in the action set
pieces were different because you had it
was mostly a lot of ocean stuff yeah I
thought was cool got a different flavor
yeah where the original 300 was on land
right is mostly like spear and sword
fighting yeah and he had the sea element
which I thought was cool and yeah the
action was entertaining they you know
obviously did the slow-motion yeah just
amped up just blew it better special
effects that opening sequence was great
even this is silly but even what they do
in the beginning with the Warner
Brothers logo in the legendary logo is
really cool and I love the opening
sequence is this big battle in the rain
we got this it slows down so much you
can see like the lightning bolts you
know little digital lightning bolts not
real but lightning bolts like just the
Lightning just going down and it just
looked great movie i thought was a
good-looking film and it was like an
hour and 45 minutes and me too long for
me yeah yeah yeah it was just perfect
lows just wrap it was two hours it could
have been too forever how much and this
is what I want to explain to me when I
say something too long it doesn't mean
that well you thought like something
like wolf of Wall Street that's three
hours long as that's too long now it has
to do with what the story is is so for
this it's only an hour 45 which doesn't
seem long but to me the story didn't
warrant an hour and 45 minute long movie
it would did simple plot of you know
revenge it was just revenge there wasn't
even that much kind of political
maneuvering at all or anything like that
it was is pretty straightforward know
when it comes to the story go straight
for but I think I've just been really
just wanting to move this but voice and
Spartacus has gone off the air and I
really won't needed a sword and sandal
epic and this delivered it form
especially after you and I saw Pompeii
Oh mommy was awful so this terrible we
even shadow review that I haven't even
no reason to postage don't see it don't
see it so I even if Jon Snow is in there
but this is a much better version of
Pompeii this is the original they know
how to do action they know how to make
it exciting and unlike like transformers
they don't make it two hours and 40
minutes long at least so no thank you
for that but I enjoyed this no I mean
it's not excessively long no I'm not
saying that I'm just saying for my taste
for what the story is it was enough for
an hour for 15-20 minutes thing could
have chopped off right but see it four
eva green I think she's worth the price
of admission alone mm-hmm and you know
we I think we both saw it in 3d yes but
he was great that's why they delayed it
supposed to come out last year but they
delayed it to not only for 3d but also
for imax 3d and did he look good I
thought it looked it was good you know
for what 3d is you know it's not gravity
or anything but it looks great yeah yeah
alright guys so that's why we thought of
300 rise of an empire let us know if
you've seen it already and what you
thought of it you can post your comments
below on the website thank you or calm
or a YouTube page think hero pro oh yeah
you also has on Twitter you'll come chat
with us about the 300 saga you know if
you've seen this you're looking forward
to a third one if they end up doing the
box office numbers especially overseas
are great it's looking over almost let's
go to 115 million dollars so hopefully
you'll get another one we're at think
hero i'm at griffin de and we also have
a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash state hero fans make sure like
that page and share our videos or really
help us out
you